pressure sores also called bed sores or
decubitus ulcers our regions of skin
that break down when you sit or lie in
one position for too long these wounds
occur most frequently in areas where
your bones are close to the skin
including your heels ankles hips
tailbone or elbows constant pressure to
one of these areas compresses the blood
vessels that supply your skin with
oxygen and vital nutrients without a
sufficient amount of blood flow your
skin cells eventually die and a pressure
sore forms pressure sores are
categorized by degrees of severity a
stage 1 pressure sore is red and
inflamed and does not blanch or become
pale when pressure is applied a stage 2
pressure sore appears as a blister or an
open sore the area surrounding the sore
may be red and irritated a stage 3
pressure sore involves a full thickness
loss of skin that appears crater-like
and extends to the layer of fat beneath
your skin
Stage four is the most severe a stage
four ulcer is a full thickness wound
that extends down to the underlying
muscle or bone to prevent infection in
your pressure sore your doctor will
clean your wound using water and a mild
soap or saline solution if your wound is
severe your doctor will debride or
surgically remove the dead tissue from
the pressure sore to protect and hydrate
your wound
your doctor may cover it with a
specialized bandage